[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv fil
78 78 voici les titres de ce lundi
emmanuel macron a promis un dialogue
exigeant sans aucune concession avec son
homologue russe vladimir poutine les
changes a eu lieu ce lundi après midi à
versailles les images à suivre et
greenpeace vient de mener une action à
travers la france contre le groupe
pétrolier total plusieurs stations
service ciblé ce week end dont celle de
bois d'arcy
l objectif alerter sur un projet de
forage au large du brésil et puis en
loisir retour sur la verticale night
l'escaladent une nouvelle fois à
l'honneur à montigny le bretonneux c'est
la deuxième édition l'actualité locale
aussi marquée par des violences
attrape deux affrontements ont éclaté ce
week-end dans la commune dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche un individu a été
agressé devant la mosquée à coups de
barres de fer et le lendemain ce sont
des affrontements qui ont éclaté dans le
quartier
albert camus entre une trentaine de
personnes la police est intervenue les
forces de l'ordre ont procédé à une
interpellation
et d'après les premiers éléments de
l'enquète il s'agirait d'une rivalité
entre bandes
écouter julien est le cam secrétaire
départemental de police alliance le
secteur en ce moment effectivement il ya
de grosses tensions entre deux bandes de
jeunes un l'issue du square léo lagrange
et albert camus voilà ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est que la nuit dernière il
ya eu cinq blessés de nouveau
à déplorer dont un très sérieusement il
faut savoir que les riverains à
l'origine on a appelé les forces de
l'ordre suite à des bruits de détonation
qui était certainement ici de tirs de
mortier mais il faut savoir que ces
tensions et peuvent
on le sait il ya deux ans il ya eu la
mort d'un jeune dans le quartier attrape
le jeune moussa qui est qu'il y avait 14
ans donc forcément ça inquiète beaucoup
les forces de l'ordre vladimir poutine
était donc à versailles ce lundi après
midi pour une rencontre avec emmanuel
macron le président français les deux
hommes ont échangé sur l'avenir de
l'union européenne mais aussi sur la
lutte antiterroriste et les différentes
crises régionales stéphane servant c'est
à versailles que le président emmanuel
macron accueil est aujourd'hui vladimir
poutine une poignée de mains appuyées
chaleureux sur le tapis rouge dans la
cour de marbre du château les deux chefs
d'état salué par la garde républicaine
ont gagné un salon pour une rencontre en
petit comité puis un déjeuner emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine sont ensuite
allé inaugurer l'exposition pierre
legrand un tsar en france consacrée au
séjour du de ça en france en 1717
l'exposition se tient au grand trianon
du 30 mai au 24 septembre 2010 est
l'occasion de découvrir plus de 150
oeuvres peintures sculptures arts
décoratifs tapisserie mais aussi livres
et manuscrits dont les deux tiers
appartiennent aux collections du
prestigieux musée de saint-pétersbourg
une exposition symbolique qui marque les
300 ans de relations diplomatiques entre
la france et la russie et plus de
détails sur ce déplacement au cours de
nos prochaines éditions la rencontre est
encore en cours à ce lundi en fin de
journée politique toujours les
associations familiales catholiques de
versailles viroflay saint quentin ont
décidé d'interpeller les candidats aux
législatives pour connaître leurs
programmes en matière de politique
familiale les afc locale organise des
soirées rencontres est elle l'une
d'entre elles vient de se tenir à
versailles en présence de plusieurs
candidats dans la 2e circonscription
détails avec ce sujet signé nicolas
quere l'oit
ils étaient sept à avoir répondu à
l'appel des afc du secteur éducation
mariage ivg les candidats présents pour
cette soirée ont pu exposer leur
position sur ces thématiques chères aux
associations familiales catholiques
inquiète après cinq ans de présidence
françois hollande nous avons connu
beaucoup de régression sur d'un point de
vue droit familial pouvoir d'achat des
familles et nous avons de plus en plus
de bénévoles qui désirent s'investir
politiquement dans notre association
pour faire bouger les choses et faire en
sorte que le balancier repartent dans
l'autre sens pour répondre aux
différentes questions pendant deux
heures un plateau politiques classés à
droite front national républicain parti
chrétien démocrate
seule la république en marche faisait
figure d'exception ces échanges était
aussi l'occasion pour les petits
candidats de faire connaître leurs
propositions sur la famille on nous
avons dans nos propositions
la notion de statut de la famille c'est
à dire que actuellement on a un homme et
une femme qui se marient mais ça reste
assez individuel nous nous proposons un
statut qui serait un petit peu celui
d'une société ou d'une fondation il faut
maintenant libérés l'école il faut
vraiment que les gens puissent monter
leur propre école que que les parents
puissent choisir leur école et que vous
verrez qu ainsi les parents iront
nécessairement vers les meilleures
écoles et que vous aurez une élévation
du niveau et que ce sera on va renouer
avec l'excellence et ce sera au bénéfice
des enfants des familles et donc de la
nation le candidat de l'union populaire
républicaine étaient aussi présents
alors que son parti n'a pas de position
officielle sur ces thématiques peu
d'élan doit récupérer les rênes
redresser l'économie
c'est la moindre des choses avant de se
poser des questions sur la famille déjà
que les familles aient les moyens
financiers
de pouvoir élever leurs enfants dans de
bonnes conditions
la fédération des associations
familiales catholiques des yvelines
rendra compte des débats organisés d'ici
à quelques jours à ses 8000 adhérents
une nouvelle soirée est prévue le 1er
juin versailles avec cette fois ci
plusieurs candidats de la première
circonscription du département pour
refermer cette page politique
aujourd'hui coup d'oeil à l'agenda de la
campagne de nombreuses réunions
publiques que ce soir notamment pour
jean-noël barrot de la république en
marche le candidat de la 2e
circonscription viendra échanger à
viroflay dès 20h30 dans la troisième
circonscription le candidat divers
droite nicolas tort dit joubert est lui
présent à la salle des fêtes du chesnay
enfin jean michel fourgous des
républicains est attendu dans la 11e
circonscription à bois d'arcy
mobilisation des mouvements greenpeace
et actions non-violentes coop à 21 dans
18 villes de france ce week end les
militants écologistes ont mené des
actions dans les stations-service du
groupe total et notamment à bois d'arcy
aux abords de la nationale 12
exploration pétrolière à cordes paris
des sujets liés à la défense de la
biodiversité
le reportage nicolas landry une station
essence total transformé en fonds marins
des dauphins des tortues et plusieurs
corps ou une action menée par une
quinzaine de militants greenpeace et
actions non violentes comme 21
objectif dénoncer les explorations de
l'entreprise pétrolière sur le récif
corallien brésilien à travers une
pétition
sa pétition demandent justement à total
d'abandonner ses projets d'exploration
pétrolière à l'invention du fleuve
amazone dans une zone en eaux profondes
et donc à risque
il ya le risque zéro n'existe pas et
donc un risque de marée noire qui
pourrait potentiellement être néfaste
pour la biodiversité du récif une
pétition qui a déjà recueilli plus d'un
million de signatures et les militants
écologistes tentent de sensibiliser
d'autres citoyens comme ils l'ont écrit
un écosystème ça n'a pas de prix
et c'est important de contacter des
choses qui sont encore vierges
de toute action humaine c'est important
aujourd'hui me semble alors qu'on a une
trace qui est de plus en plus indélébile
sur la planète l'environnement c'est ce
qui nous permet de vivre donc forcément
c'est important quand on va
comment on pollue la planète avec tous
les diesels et
forcément que c'est important plusieurs
messages d alerte avec notamment la
défense des engagements inscrits dans
l'accord de paris lors de la cop 21 en
on avait décidé à paris de ne pas
dépasser les + 2 degrés en fin de compte
on se rend compte que si total continue
à forer
des sites pétroliers un peu partout
autour du globe ça va pas le faire ce
midi effectivement il ya eu donald trump
qui a déclaré vouloir se donner une
marge de manoeuvre le temps de réfléchir
aux engagements a priori c'est mal
engagé
une déclaration du président des états
unis lors du g7 à taormine en sicile le
respect des conditions de l'accord de
paris devrait revenir dans les débats
lors du g20 à hambourg les 7 et 8
juillet prochains
une initiative originale à présent à
saint quentin en yvelines réunis autour
de leur professeur de physique-chimie
une dizaine de lycéens de présence
bretonne et ont préparé un ballon sonde
pour des expériences sur l'atmosphère
préparation et concentration avant le
lancement grand moment pour ces élèves
de seconde et de terminale du lycée
descartes de voisins-le-bretonneux le
lancement de leur ballon sonde ils ont
travaillé tous les mercredis après midis
depuis près d'un an qu'on a avec les
élèves conçu une nacelle dans laquelle
on a mis plusieurs séries de capteurs et
puis des caméras grâce à l' enthousiasme
de leur professeur de physique chimie
une dizaine d'élèves a imaginé des
expériences calcul de pression de
température mesure d'ozone qu'on a fait
la nacelle on a testé les déposants on a
discuté de tout ce qui allait se passer
à travers le projet une spécialiste des
balles on va les aider à effectuer le
décollage les autorisations nécessaires
auprès de la mairie de l'aviation civile
ont été obtenues tout est planifié
certains s'occupent du gonflage de tenir
le ballon d'autres de l'assemblage final
une check list comme pour une fusée ça
c'est la fiche de vol et signa où il
n'ya pas de croix on n'en voit pas tout
est prêt
le vol doit durer trois heures moment
d'émotion et de joie pour tous c'est
vrai que à voir ce ballon sengler dans
les
c'est magique chauffe après avoir
atteint la stratosphère à près de 26
mille mètres d'altitude
le ballon a explosé et la nacelle est
descendu freiné par son parachute
atterrissage réussi à une cinquantaine
de kilomètres la nacelle est retrouvée
grâce aux radios amateurs qui suivait le
trajet en temps réel la nacelle est
intacte toutes les données de vol vont
pouvoir être récupérés et analysés une
grande expérience pour ces lycéens et
leurs professeurs
nous ouvrons une page sportive à présent
dans cette édition du lundi ce sont de
véritables les athlètes aussi habile que
des lézards lorsqu'il s'agit de grimper
ce sont les meilleurs professionnels et
amateurs est de l' escalade de blocs qui
se sont affrontés au cours d'une
compétition samedi dernier retour sur
cette verticale night c'est le nom de
l'événement c'était à montigny le
bretonneux camille lambert trouver la
meilleure prise et se hisser avec
agilité un sentiment incomparable pour
ces grimpeurs
ils étaient plus de 250 à s'affronter
lors de la compétition vertica night à
montigny-le-bretonneux amateurs et
professionnels ont partagé des 50 bloc
de qualification on avait déjà fait une
première édition l'année dernière
ces compétitions on essaie de réunir les
meilleurs grimpeurs du moment des
grimpeurs
nationale internationale et en même
temps mêlé
à une compétition amateur en fait donc
avoir des professionnels de l'escaladé
en même temps à voir le rappeur amateur
mis sur le même rang compétition
d'escaladé de bloc ce sport apparues au
cours des années 1900 consiste à grimper
des blocs de faible hauteur toute la
soirée les grimpeurs ont investi le
terrain de jeu de plus de 1000 mètres
carrés et certains sont venus de loin
pour participer à l'événement comme éric
lopez grimpeur espagnol
[Applaudissements]
j'aime toujours les compétitions dans
tous les sports et en espagne les
compétitions d'escaladé sont différentes
j'aime les faire à l'étranger comme ça
je peux me préparer au niveau
international et j'ai aussi de très bons
amis ici en france les trois meilleurs
de la compétition se sont partagé un
prix de 4500 euros
et si l'aventuré vous tente non prochain
vous pouvez vous entraîner à la salle en
semaine elle est ouverte jusqu'à 23h et
pour refermer ce journal les images des
34e min puces de montigny le bretonneux
vide greniers convivial où les chineurs
se sont retrouvés tout au long de la
journée 113 exposants présents pour
cette édition
pour certains cela fait plus de vingt
ans qu'il participe une tradition
incontournable
les exposants apprécié l'accueil le
lâche alors aussi avec laquelle ils sont
reçus et la façon qu'ils exposent parce
que nous sommes quand même une petite
structure et
ça leur convient tout à fait c'est tout
à fait le lien social traditionnel de
l'association vivre c'est le sait là
c'est le seul but de notre association
c'est l'organisation de ces mini puce
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal les
programmes se poursuivre sur tv fil 78
replay disponible sur notre site
internet et applications mobiles
[Musique]